[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to another episode of
whatsa Prof hello Walter hi
there so what are we talking on a seal
and a mark a seal or a
mark yeah well it's not one of those
flapp seals
right no not not that one okay now this
is a serious seal all right well let's
get into it let's open with a word of
prayer our heavenly father thank you for
blessing us and bringing us together
again we ask that you please bless this
discussion Enlighten our minds keep us
safe and focused in Jesus name amen
amen you know there's so much talk
always about the
ceiling and what it means and so many
questions about it and so many arguments
that especially the world out there has
with regards to the
mark that we thought well maybe we
should just talk a little bit about
seals and
marks and then each one can decide for
himself yeah whether that's biblical or
not and in light of what you've shown or
if shown in the previous WhatsApp Prof
as
well there will be a time when this will
become prevalent and especially Martin
because we are especially in our last
WhatsApp Prof we are moving towards this
time when church and state is coming
together so very soon it's either the
seal or the mark right that's true you
have to have one or the other you're
going to and and it will be one or or
the other otherwise you will have the
State against you yeah you can't sit on
the fence with this one it's one or the
other so Revelation 7 verse three talks
about the SE Servants of God that are
sealed in their
fors now the new translations say on
their
forets the King James says in their
forets which I believe is the correct
translation because it means your
thinking pattern your cognitive
decisions that you have made
right so we have to wait until the
Servants of God are sealed in their fors
and then in Revelation 1316 you have the
beast's Mark is placed in their right
hand or in their
foreheads so obviously there is a choice
here either the Seal of God
or the mark of the beast one of the
two and Revelation
13:17 says that no one may buy or sell
except one who has the Mark or the name
of the Beast or the number of his name
mhm so in other words if you choose
between the two and you don't choose the
mark there are
repercussions there are consequences to
that refusal right yeah yeah
so it starts with
economic problems I wonder whether
tariffs will be increased 25% 50 no 200
I don't know it's going to work but
it'll be interesting to see how it
starts off and then eventually you will
not be able to buy or sell at
all so it's a question Martin of who do
you serve yeah that's the bottom line is
that the bottom line Romans 6:16 know ye
not that to whom you yield yourself
servants to obey he servants you are to
whom you obey whether of sin unto death
or of obedience unto
righteousness so Martin this is a very
interesting verse so if you commit sin
now the definition of sin transgression
of the law all right which leads to
death the wages of sin is death Eternal
death Eternal death so transgression of
the law leads to Eternal death or
obedience to the law leads unto
righteousness or let us rather put it
that put it slightly differently if we
compare with the other verses that Paul
is speaking about if you make your
decision to forsake your sins and to
confess your sins
then he is righteous and just and
forgives you your sins and gives you his
robe of
righteousness and once you have embraced
this issue then the justification will
be made manifest by obedience to the
Commandments yes so in other words you
will show that by do it will be an
outflow that you are doing it that's how
you show that you've Incorporated it it
like righteousness yes all right so now
the churches are all very confused on
this
issue because why would the devil be
thrown
out because of
sin and people be led in with sin yeah
then you would just be replacing what
was thrown out in the first place right
yes so obviously transgression of the
law which is sin must cease mhm and not
one jot or one title will by any means
disappear from the law so you know this
these verses by Paul are often Twisted
so that they say the opposite of what
they should be saying because he lays
emphasis on righteousness by faith
doesn't negate the law do we thereby get
rid of the law no God forbid we uphold
the law and establish
it so we need to know what is the seal
and what does it mean to have a mark
yeah so I thought it was perhaps a good
idea to get a very modern Source
something like Uncle
Google so let's ask Google there's the
the web page there what is the seal what
is it and I found their definition
rather good as a matter of fact I was
quite surprised to get something good
out of
Google it's says a seal of authority
refers to a symbol or
Mark you see that the interchangeability
with a Mark isn't that interesting it's
amazing it's already there this is
Google
right often an official seal or stamp or
used to authenticate documents
signifying the legitimacy and binding
power of a law a decree or other
official action I thought that was
excellent yeah because it's linking it
to a law it's linking it to a law it's
linking it to a a
mark and then what was the purpose of a
seal of authority well number one it was
authentication a seal serves as a visual
confirmation that a document or action
is genuine and
authorized now uh sometimes the seal as
in the case of the one that we read
about in the Bible is in your for it so
you'd have to have some surgery to go
see it right so that's true but in your
fruits yes that's the visible yes you're
right perfect answer thank
you and then legitimacy it conveys the
authority and power of the person or
institution issuing the document or
action so it's all about
Authority main thing and then protection
I found that interesting there's an
element of protection in the seal that's
beautiful actually isn't that nice yeah
because we know where we're going of
it's amazing in the past seals protected
documents from being tampered with or
forged you can't mess with it what if
you change the document it's protected
by the seal then you you negate the
authority of the person that put the
seal there yes so it had a little click
where you can say more so you can get
some more information so I thought okay
give me
more and what it said
was historical
context in ancient times seals were used
to authenticate Royal
decrees contracts and other important
documents the Seal of a king or ruler
would contain their name title and the
territory they ruled signifying their
Authority I that was spot on too I was
impressed with Uncle Google or is it
Auntie Google I don't know probably
Professor
Google at least it's no longer no
pronoun or correct pronoun Google
because now we only have two genders
right
it's not the and they whatever so these
are very important points MH and I
thought they very relevant to the topic
so if we apply all of these points and
we ask what is the Seal of God yeah then
it must uh more or less fit into this
framework isn't that so very much
so all right so what is the Seal of God
well Isaiah 8:16 tell tells us bind up
the
testimony seal the law among my
disciples so there's two things that the
Disciples of God must have yeah the law
and the testimony the law and the
testimony do we read that somewhere in
Revelation 12 yes 12: 17 uhhuh but also
I think in Revelation 19 vers 10 and the
dragon was wroth with the woman and went
to make war with a rem of her seed those
that hold to the testimony or that keep
the law and hold to the
testimony so the testimony is what all
the prophets testified to and the law
was the first portion of the Bible the
Torah which contained The Ten
Commandments and that was to be
sealed among the the disciples in other
words it was to be written in their
hearts and in their minds that's it is
what's the taste to the law and to the
testimony Now isn't that the New
Covenant that I will write my law in
their hearts
right so if we look at the
criteria Exodus
31:13 says speak thou also unto the
children of Israel saying verily my
sabbaths ye shall keep for it is a sign
between me and you throughout your
Generations that you may know that I am
the Lord that does sanctify you so where
does your sanctification come from by
living a great life oh by by being
perfectly obedient to everything and
picking yourself up by your
bootstraps and there you go to heaven
right
definitely not that's not what that
verse is saying that's not what the
verse says no the verse says that the
Lord is the one that sanctifies you it's
not something you can achieve it is an
alien righteousness that is imputed to
you and an in working of his spirit that
enables yeah yeah okay now why would he
say that the Sabbath is the one that is
the sign
between you the word there is oath which
is also a mark mhm wow what we've read
which we saw was parallel to a seal yes
and that he is the one that sanctifies
you now if you go to that commandment
the Sabbath commandment remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy six days
shall you labor etc etc and then it said
for in six days the Lord mhm that is the
name of the Lord Lord Giver yve yeah the
Lord your
God made that means that's his title is
the
Creator and his jurisdiction his
territory Heaven and Earth therefore he
commanded you to keep the Sabbath day so
the Sabbath is the Seal of God
yes but it's not only the Sabbath
because the Sabbath authenticates the
entire law or document yeah so the
document is there containing everything
this is just the the Seal Seal on top of
authority yeah and you don't mess with
the seal you can't change anything all
right so what does it seal well the law
and the testimony that's the whole Bible
yeah but uh it's in the heart of the ten
commandments so it's also in the heart
of the law that's actually a seal on the
Ten Commandments as well now once that
seal has been put on there can you
change it no no but whatever power comes
along and says I'm going to change it
then he's going to have to deal with the
law with The Giver of that seal he has
to either kill him and get rid of him
and say I'm the new law or else he's
going to have a conflict of interests
yeah is that
correct now the little horn power wasn't
that going to change the law yes huh
it's going to change it think to change
it well if you're changing the law and
you want to have your Authority placed
upon it then mustn't you put another
seal on it yes cuz now it's a new law
it's almost like forging it now you've
taken it and you made it your own okay
okay you put another seal on it right so
a government has stupid laws the next
government comes along resends those
laws Chucks all of the previous
administration's laws out rights many uh
executive
orders and changes them all then a new
signature has to go under and a new
stamp of approval and new seal right
that's how you change the law you have
to undo what the previous one
did but what if that previous one's law
is so unchangeable that not one jot or
title may be moved what then then you're
going to get trouble and you change it
anyway what then O then you're in big
trouble okay so then you're in big
trouble but can we say that according to
the definition of
Google that this is the one
law that conforms to all the criteria
that are necessary for a seal yeah
definitely right they said the name the
title and the
territory because if I gave you an order
and told you that you will do x y and
Zed and signed it with my name you will
probably have a good laugh and throw it
into the waste paper basket or you would
throw a tantrum one of the two right
yeah but uh if somebody with a little
bit more clout who can put you in jail
if you don't writes that law that's a
different story right well I'll put it
like this if you gave me a traffic
traffic ticket I'll laugh at it you
laugh at me yes but if a traffic cop
gives it to me then it's a little bit
different yes if if somebody you know
tries to reprimand you on the road it
normally leads to road
rage definitely not listening to them
all right so we've
established that this commandment the
fourth
Commandment is absolutely in line with
the
seal Deuteronomy
6:2 that thou must fear the lord thy God
to keep all his statues and his
Commandments which I command thee thou
and thy son and thy son son all the days
of thy life and that thy days may be
prolonged and then he continues in verse
six and these words which I command thee
this day shall be in thine heart and
thou shalt teach them diligently unto
thy children and shallal talk of them
when thou sest in thine house and when
thou wst by the way and when thou liest
down and when they thou risest up so
must this be the principle that dictates
your life it must be entrenched in your
life it must be a
lifestyle to have so fear God and keep
his Commandments this is the whole duty
of man isn't that what Solomon wrote
that's it it must be in your being it
mustn't be something that you have to
get up and put on or try and work it
must be part of so must be the principle
of your life and you know Solomon was
one who found out by painful
experience that this is the principle of
life
because imagine having 200 wives all
with opposite opinions that must have
been quite a and that's just the 200
wives not the 800 or 600 that's not the
concubines no yeah that's about a
thousand
then and thou shalt bind them for a sign
there's that word again this o upon
thine hand and they shall be as
frontlets between Thine Eyes in other
words you must act accordingly and you
must be informed or think accordingly
yes you it is something that you've
decided I want to do it must become a
mindset all right so seal up the
law and the
testimony and here he breaks it down and
he says the
Commandments and the Seal of Authority
for that law which authenticates it all
you find in the fourth
Commandment okay what is the difference
between Commandments and statutes well
there were many rules that God gave and
some of them were civil statutes some of
them were Health statutes some of them
were um moral statutes Etc
so uh it's a
collective but the Ten Commandments were
written separately and deemed of such
centrality that they were written with a
finger of God placed onto tables of
stone and were borne around in the ark
of the testimony shielded by a mercy
seat because the letter of the law
condemned you to death as a sinner so
you had to be shielded from the
condemnation by the mercy seed yes the
hust Aron yes the atonement the
atment very nice theology so is it also
can we also see it that the statutes is
a consequence of the of sin yes that
came but it cannot be changed it can
only be fulfilled correct so some of
some of them like the ceremonial
Commandments and statutes were
fulfilled but the moral issues are
Eternal they're written in stone it and
and by the time we get to heaven even
the other statutes will then be
fulfilled and we don't they have to but
the moral will keep on but we know where
they have to go you have to have them in
your hand that means you act accordingly
and you must be here in your frontal
loes that you must think accordingly now
where does the mark of the beast go
either or it goes either onto the hand
or between the eyes in other words you
will do as you're told mhm or
else or I'll convince you that I'm right
yeah and then you'll do it because you
think it's right yeah one of the two but
God wants none of this wishy-washy stuff
he says hand and between the eyes that's
almost like your free will uh a free
choice yes you decide and then you
because you believe it you act upon it
correct Ephesians 4:30 says and grieve
not the holy spirit of God whereby ye
are sealed unto the day of
redemption there's another seal now this
seal Martin is actually burning it into
your
mind so what was it that had to be
sealed the law and the
testimony and it had to be sealed into
the mind so that it stays there and
doesn't go away until the day of
redemption
you have to really be
convicted just just
question so that seal is not something
you can do the holy spirit is doing that
inside of you who convicts you of sin
the Holy Spirit what is the job of the
Holy Spirit to convict of sin and
righteousness and
judgment so first you are convicted of
sin I'm a transgressor of the
law then I'm convicted about
righteousness well who who has
righteousness obviously I don't have it
because I'm a transgressor Christ has
the righteousness so there's my solution
to my sin
problem and on the day of redemption
judgment will have
been executed
yeah so let's go to Revelation
7:3 saying hurt not the Earth neither
the sea nor the trees till we have
sealed the Servants of our God in their
foreheads so where must this conviction
lie in your cognitive it must be a
decision it must be a decision Martin is
this therefore a physical seal or is it
a spiritual seal it's more a spiritual
seal okay so I don't have to go and look
for a bank stamp or a barcode on
somebody's head or a tattoo or a uh
vacine or well yes or an
implant even if it is the size of a
grain of rice yeah this is a spiritual
ceiling it is a decision that you have
made regarding a particular Authority
and theology yes okay so here's a
statement in the book Last Day Events
just as soon as the people of God are
sealed in their forets it is not any
seal or Mark that can be
seen but a settling into the truth both
intellectually and spiritually so they
cannot be moved just as soon as God's
people are sealed and prepared for the
shaking it will come indeed it has begun
already so M it's it's not a physical
sign and from all the verses that we
have read it seems quite obvious that
that it is a spiritual issue and that
God through his holy spirit impresses
the mind one way or the other now you
want to have the Seal of God right yes
yes and you want it in your mind and you
want to act
accordingly so the statutes and the
Commandments have to be written there
and they are the
seal and the seal authenticates a
document mhm namely the law and the
testimony therefore you cannot mess with
it and you cannot change it it's like
the law of mes and Persians once it's
gone out that's it not one jot or one
title will by any means disappear from
that law but that settling into the
truth also is interesting because this
whole episode of this spiritual thing is
based on truth it's based B on truth and
what is truth the word is truth the law
is truth and Christ is truth they're all
there because you can't have
righteousness without
Christ and you won't understand the
issue if you don't have the the law and
the
testimony so now that we've established
that the Seal of God is a spiritual seal
and not a physical
seal that it is embodies the
authentication of a document the law and
the
testimony that particularly the
requirements of God the Ten
Commandments are to be embedded in the
mind and you must act accordingly then
we must ask ourselves what are the other
marks in the
Bible now there's an interesting Mark in
the Bible which is called The Mark of
Cain yeah wouldn't you like to know what
that is oh
definitely okay now if you go to the
ancient cult cultures whether it's the
Assyrian or the Babylonian
culture they depicted what happened in
the anti- deluvian
world as deified forms of those
individuals so the early rulers and the
early anti- delians like Abel or Cain or
any one of them they were later deified
as gods and it's interesting that the
God that was served in this time was
Marduk now
Marduk had authority to control
evil so he was the deity that had
authority to incarcerate or punish or
keep in check any form of evil and he
received that Authority from another
deity that was called Anu
uhhuh and Marduk had the sign of Anu and
he had a sword and he had a
trident now the other deities like
Poseidon for example or Neptune whatever
you want to call him they also had
Trident and Trident are very interesting
because they normally had wavy and
straight spokes which refer to the male
and the female as ects we don't have to
go into all the details the sword is
very important because the sword implies
Authority and power to enforce what you
are going to dictate right and then he
had the sign of Anu now the sign of
Anu was here on his arm it looks like a
watch but it's actually eight spokes
basically two crosses over each other so
that is eight spokes that was the sign
of Anu or the sign of authority if you
could enlarge this picture you will see
there's a ring around the Hem all with
signs of Anu on them saying he had the
authority to rule over evil
okay now this book by tapasi rulers of
evil is a very very interesting book
because it talks
about uh this very issue and it takes
the mythologies of the of the ancient
world and tries to determine who has
this power and uh you know you have
reliefs like these and you find them
also in the capital on on the ceiling
and there you have the sword in the hand
and the shield ruling over the
disobedient
so this authority to rule M was is the
sword usually in the hands of the state
the sword is in the hands of the state
but there is a sword that is higher than
the sword of the state namely the sword
that the church wields yeah the one is
the spiritual sword the other one is the
secular sword but the spiritual sword is
deemed higher in Authority than the
secular sword therefore the secular
sword must must be subject to the
spiritual sword so this is a union of
church and state now the one cover that
we have for this particular book is the
one that we see there on the
left and this would be what you will
find for example in the capital of the
United States of America in Washington
DC another cover of of the same book
in other
printings has a Jesuit priest with a
sign of Ano on it which is very
interesting because tapasi came to the
conclusion that the spiritual sword
behind the secular
sword was enforced through a military
order yeah and he said it was the
Jesuits now that's a conclusion he came
to based on his
research and uh personally I think he's
he's hit the nail on the head for sure
if you use the other source that we have
the spirit of Prophecy it says the same
thing the same thing all
right now let's just unpack The Mark of
Cain in Genesis 4:8 we read and Cain
talked with Abel his brother and it came
to pass when they were both in this
field that Cain wrote rose up against
Abel his brother and slew him now the
reason why he did it is because Abel's
sacrifice of the Lamb was accepted
whereas Cain's sacrifice of the produce
that he brought from the hands of his
labor was
rejected in other words these are two
different plans of Salvation yes the the
the one is salvation by faith mhm in the
atoning blood of the lamb and the other
one is salvation by your own works now
the one that is accepted is the one that
puts the faith in the sacrifice to come
of which the lamb was a type yeah and it
referred to Jesus Christ so salvation in
Christ accepting the righteousness of
Christ through his atoning
blood that is acceptable with God there
is no way that you can be saved through
your works so this is two religious
systems and the and the scary thing is
both sacrificed both sacrificed but the
one the works of his hands the labor of
his hands salvation by works and the
other one by relying on a redeemer to
come where the work was outside of
himself it was an alien righteousness
that he relied on and it shows you the
two mindsets two mindsets in the world
now most religious systems in the world
have the mindset of cane yeah so let's
continue the story so he went and he
rose up and he
slew
Abel the two mindsets never shall meet
the one will always persecute the other
and that's the story of
History verse 10 says and he said said
what hast thou done this is now God the
voice of thy brother's blood crith unto
me from the
ground and now art thou cursed from the
earth which has opened her mouth and
received thy brother's blood from my thy
hand when thou tillest the ground it
shall not henceforth yield unto thee her
strength a fugitive and a vagabond shalt
thou be in the Earth
and Cain said unto the Lord my
punishment is greater than I can
bear behold thou has driven me out this
day from the face of the Earth and from
the face shall I be hid from thy face
shall I be hid and I shall be a fugitive
and a vagabond in the earth and it shall
come to pass that everyone that findeth
me shall slay me so he's asking the
question how do I prevent people from
slaying me well there's a couple of
interesting things here Martin number
one that's very interesting is that he's
hidden from the face of God does that
mean that Cain should always be lost
well he could be saved if he accepted
the sacrifice of Abel yeah but if he
rejects it then he's hidden from the
face of God it's a choice that's it and
how's he going to protect himself
against all
that wanted to get rid of him yeah so
obviously he must get some power or
something that will enable him to
sustain
himself verse 15 says and the Lord said
unto him therefore whosoever slay us
Cain Vengeance shall be taken on him
Sevenfold and the Lord set a mark upon
Cain lest any finding him should kill
him H it's interesting right so here
Cain receives The Mark of Cain did he
get a physical sign well from what we've
read none of those signs that we've read
about were physical signs they were
all they all as a consequence of a
mindset yes so what Mark of Cain did he
receive well number one we know what his
mindset was his mindset was I will be
saved by my works
but how's he going to prevent people
from you know getting rid of him there
must be a seal so he must have some kind
of authority so what Authority did he
get well he could take Vengeance
Sevenfold yeah so in other words if you
do something to
me you're going to suffer my friend
because I'm going to punish you
Sevenfold who has more Authority then
you me yeah because I can tell you I'm
gonna I'm going to do this Sevenfold now
the number seven is interesting because
God is the number seven so he's actually
taking a prerogative that the deity had
to punish the wages of sin is death and
lends it to
Cain he get an
authority so let's read the story
further and Cain knew his wife and she
conceived and be Enoch that's the first
born of Cain
now people always ask who was his wife
well obviously must have been one of his
sisters right there was no genetic
imperfection at that time so it was
perfectly safe to marry a sister and
even Abraham still married his half
sister and later on when the genetic
imperfections increased then they were
admonitions that you shouldn't marry
within the
family but his first son was called
Enoch now this is Enoch son of Cain not
the good not Enoch the seventh from Adam
no and he builded a city and called the
name of the city after the name of his
son Enoch okay so Cain became a city
dweller now in a city there are many
people that need to be
controlled and he became the ruler of
those people
and he had to keep these people that had
the mindset of Cain under
control they were inclined to be law
Breakers I wonder why so in a sense he
became
Marduk who controlled the children of
evil now the question is why would God
give Cain the permission to rule and
punish the children of evil in his
cities uh I always tell the story my
wife she was a school
teacher and she was also in a school
once where there were many people from
very disadvantaged
backgrounds and as often is the case
they were often on drugs and were
violent and they were in gangs so it was
a very dangerous place to to to be and
of course the children in the classes
were often a lot older than they should
be because they' failed once or twice or
three or four or five times in a row
because of their
unruliness and she tried as a rather
Meek and Mild person to retain Law and
Order which became
impossible so in an act of desperation
she once said she's not going to apply
any rules and regulations anymore
because obviously they don't listen they
ignore it so she said to them you will
become the police and you will apply the
Law and Order so now let's see how we're
going to deal with it if somebody
whistles and talks and doesn't listen in
class then uh what is going to be your
punishment and who's going to see to it
that it doesn't happen because it
doesn't work when I do it cuz you don't
listen to me anyway so you're going to
make the rules and you're going to give
the
punishment so they made the rules no
talking in class
Punishment No walking around no throwing
objects in class punishment etc etc a
whole long list of rules and the
punishments were unbelievably harsh yeah
because they thought it up themselves
they thought it up themselves it was at
least seven
times or much more than would have than
she would have done for example one of
the rules was there was a foyer that had
to be scrubbed with a toothbrush on your
knees it was a huge fire for a whole
school so your knees were shot when you
were through with the process so the
rules were very strict or how many times
you had to run around a field or
something and they enforced them
yeah so she having lost the authority
they weren't going to listen anyway made
them rulers of evil yeah and it worked
of course
perfectly okay so he built a city and he
named it after his son Enoch and Enoch
unto Enoch was born irat and irat begat
meel and Mel begat meus and meus begot
lamech and lamech took unto him two
wives the name of the one was adah and
the name of the other was Zilla so this
is the first time you have more than one
wife so this is a progression that
happened moving away from God yes and
now it's just on a downward spiral it's
on a downward spiral and lame said unto
his wives aah and Zilla hear my voice ye
wives of lamech hearken unto my speech
for I have slain a man to my wounding
and the young man to my hurt so did he
get better or did he get worse worse so
worse he was now the first since Cain to
have slain somebody that's mentioned in
the bible so the first one was Cain the
second ruler was Enoch and then it tells
you down the line what happened and then
lame came to power but he was a harsh
man and he had more than one wife for
the first time in in the history of
humanity and he increased the law by
saying if Cain shall be Avenged
Sevenfold truly lamech 70 and sfold now
if you go to Genesis 4:4 that same verse
in the Geneva Bible I'll read it as
though it's written in Modern English it
read reads and Cain shall be Avenged
Sevenfold truly lame 70 times
Sevenfold that's very interesting I
think this is the intent of the verse so
we should read it if Cain shall be
Avenged Sevenfold then lame 70 times
Sevenfold now let's just jump a little
bit ahead if you get to
Daniel The Book of Daniel there were 70
weeks allotted to the children of Israel
right 70 * 7 yeah and if you take that
number and you jump to the time of
Christ the question is how often shall I
forgive my brother 70 * 7 70 * 7 so that
would be 490 times so Martin if your
wife irritates you 490 times after that
it's tickets
right no so what did that actually mean
well when you come to the 70 weeks the
70 weeks were allotted to
Israel and what happened after the 70
weeks their probation closed as a nation
right so basically it means you must
forgive till probation closes so could
we read it if Cain shall be Avenged
Sevenfold truly lamech will receive the
power until probation closes to wield
this power to control anyone that wants
to interfere with his rulership yes you
can read it like that could we could we
perhaps read it like that all right
would be just interesting oh so these
people became rulers now we want to take
it through to Modern Times And ask
ourselves what is going on here so let's
go to let's call it the Bible of
Freemasonry this is morals and Dogma by
Albert Pike and he has a very
interesting statement on page
210 it says
Enoch his name signified in the Hebrew
initiate or
initiator the legend of The Columns of
granite and Brass of bronze erected by
him is probably symbol
that of bronze which survived the flood
which is nonsense of course is supposed
to be to symbolize the mysteries of
which masonry is the legitimate
successor from the earliest times the
custodian and depository of the great
philosophical and religious truths
unknown To The World At Large and handed
down from age to age by an unbroken
current of tradition embodied in symbols
and emblems and
allegories so in other words the the
philosophy of
Freemasonry and the traditions and the
symbols and the allegories are handed
down from the time of
Enoch which Enoch the or the son of Cain
for sure the son of Cain so we needed to
figure that out now there's another
portion in that in morals and Dogma
where it actually gives the ages ah and
from that we can deduce that it cannot
possibly be Enoch the good one because
he came much
later but that it referred to the time
of Enoch son of Cain so that's where
this power that is wielded behind the
scenes comes from and it will be wielded
to the End of
Time further on in the Masonic writings
we learn that Nimrod is the one after
the flood that perpetuated this
philosophy obviously ham had full
knowledge of the Mysteries he had huge
brain and he was not exactly the most
faithful of the sons of Noah and he had
this philosophy and this dichotomy in
his mind and passed some
onto his
posterity and then
Nimrod he this one of the sons of kush
he's the one that is the initiator of
modern Freemasonry yeah but actually
it's the same philosophy that came all
the way from Cain and they wielded a
particular Authority and his name means
Rebel yes that's also rebeling against
God against God it's having a another
mindset and another Plan of Salvation
now let's go back to those ancient
reliefs and see if we can find something
here is one that dates from 823 to 811
BC and this is the ruler Shashi Adat the
5th and let's have a look at a couple of
symbols he again has the same watch that
Marduk had on you don't see the face of
it in this case but there is this eight
spoked Circle M and that is the sign of
Anu and then you have looks like a
compass right like a compass and set
Square you have the symbol of Bal Hadad
you have something that could be akin to
what we call the atic calendar these
days and then you have a Triple Crown
over there that's very interesting and
you have to ask yourself if you go down
the line of History who has all of these
symbols very interesting as to what is
around his neck because that is a malse
cross obviously has nothing to do with
Calvary because this is 823 to 811 BC
exactly so the males cross is very
important then he has this belt and
there you can see him holding on to the
shaft of his sword his authority and on
his other arm is definitely also the
sign of there's the sign of Anu so
Martin what we have here is all of those
symbols
and these powerful
rulers they were the ones that received
their power to rule from
Marduk and on behalf of Marduk they
would control the children of
Disobedience yeah that's the line of
Cain so with all of that in mind let's
continue to the mark of the
beast so we've had The Mark of Cain it's
obviously a symbol that gave him
authority to protect himself against any
forces that would want to interfere with
his
Rule and he founded the cities City yeah
and the allegories and the symbols which
according to masonry give honor to
Lucifer and it's a system of Salvation
by works that's always the bottom line
same as Kane same as Cain
now Martin the biggest sign of Anu in
the world today you find in the Vatican
Square there it is there are the eight
lines yeah of two crosses one inside the
other so that's the sign of authority
from Anu yeah to give so Anu is the one
who gave him the authority now if you go
to the Bible the one who permitted him
to rule over evil was God himself yeah
yeah but the one who is actually
worshiped is
Marduk so here is the symbol of this
Authority so Martin when he put tapasi
when he put the Jesuits on the cover
with the sign of Anu around their neck
he said well are they the ones who are
ruling behind the scenes yeah yeah
that's what he
said now what is then the mark of the
beast we know what the mark of God Is So
what's the mark of the beast Revelation
and the third Angel followed them saying
with a loud voice if any man worship the
Beast and His Image and receive his Mark
in his forehead or in his
hand that one will be exposed to the
wrath of God right yeah so you're not
supposed to do that so who is the Beast
just a question obviously from what
we've discussed now it's easy to detract
what why they will be
um consequences if they take that Mark
correct because it's the opposite of
Salvation and it's taking the Seal of
God in it's destroying it like we've
mentioned in Google it says or earlier
that if somebody messes with it you
can't mess with it you're going to have
trouble so here's another power that is
usurping the power and this Authority
comes in an unbroken line down from
Enoch son of Cain all the way way
through ham to Nimrod who again
established it in his fullness and
decided to build a tower of bab so that
God would not destroy them again now God
had already promised that he would not
destroy them with water so they defied
the promise of God again so you don't
believe the promises of God you don't
believe that the Messiah would come to
put enmity between thy seed and her seed
etc etc you don't believe the Plan of
Salvation
so now this beast and all the reformers
were of one Accord that this Beast
represented
Catholicism now I find it fascinating
that they have the largest sign of Anu
in the entire world in their key
establishment now let's just go to it
and ask them the Roman Catholic church
now what is your mark of authority
they said Sunday is our Mark of
authority the church is above the Bible
and this transference of Sabbath
observance is proof of that fact is that
an arrogant statement that's blasphemy
that's blasphemy right that is you can't
get more arrogant I think that's about
the same as Cain said that's about the
same as Cain is and they have the mark
of
Anu and K had the mark of Anu and nimod
took it he built the city yeah didn't
Enoch build the city same thing and
Nimrod built the city for sure these
people love cities right H all right so
he's above the Bible so he's making
himself a law unto himself saying I will
remove that seal that is in the Sabbath
Commandment that gives Authority and I
will place my own seal upon it so Sunday
is our Mark of authority given this Day
by Pope so and so
jurisdiction Heaven and
Earth so he believes because he puts a
triple crown on his head just like that
Assyrian King had and that triple crown
says I am the ruler of Heaven Earth and
the
underworld so you are ruler over the
living and the Dead usurping God's
Authority completely absolutely and
taking it and putting their
putting their stamp and their seal on it
so let's just make sure that they really
mean this so this is ringer the previous
cope and he said the EU must keep Sunday
says the Catholic
church this was in the days of
ringa and Pope John Paul II who has been
declared a saint has said a person who
violates the sanctity of Sunday is to be
punished as a heretic
now Martin how were Heretics punished by
torture and death
ah so I think they're pretty serious
here right so Martin does this signify
that they want to wield their Authority
yeah for sure that sword now M if you
accept this sign or this Mark of their
Authority does that mean that you ackn
this authority over and above the word
of God yes then you it's another
Authority that because if the one says
this and the other one this and you the
one that you decide to go with is what
you're going to do okay but where's the
Seal of God supposed to be in your
forehead in your and in your hand ah and
the mark either or so either or you
either have it in your hand you do what
you told or you don't worry about you
don't believe it but you just do it
because you have to yeah and the other
one is okay I go along with this because
I believe that Jesus changed the law
yeah so he ripped his own seal off I'm
listening to what this other entity is
saying yes and I give my power unto the
pope and therefore we will invent
purgatory and the pope is the one who
releases you from the punishment of sin
and not Jesus Christ on the cross it's a
pretty serious issue is this two kinds
of
Salvation completely this is exactly the
back to can and able
okay so Martin I find it
interesting that in
2005 this Jesuit priest Joseph
fesio said on Meet the Press and by the
way this one is the founder of Ignatius
press so he's you know that tells you
something said that those who rebel
against the church's authentic teachings
are rebelling against God now what if
those teachings are d metrically
supposed to what the Bible says then
what God are you rebelling against they
God isn't it interesting that the pope
wears
white isn't that the color of
righteousness isn't that the prerogative
of Christ and he's the only one allowed
to do that yes that's very interesting
so Martin this is another form of
Salvation which entails the salvation by
works now how important is this power
H well Thomas ainus said that the pope
by Divine Right has spiritual and
temporal power as Supreme king of the
world yeah but does he not wield The
Mark of Cain then definit thing he rules
over evil then as well okay but the pope
has this
power the pope of Rome as the head of
the papal government claims absolute
sovereignty and Supremacy over all the
governments of the
earth that's an interesting
quote so he has all the authority yeah
so whose seal goes onto a document he
seal so you either have the Seal of God
or you have the Seal of the Pope you
have the Seal of the god of heaven or
the one that claims to be God on this
Earth that stands higher than the Bible
he said so he said
yeah then Cardinal Manning said that the
right of deposing kings is inherent in
the Supreme sovereignty which the popes
as Vice regions of Christ exercise over
all Christian
nations the previous quote said all
nations so Cardinal Manning was just
being a little bit careful in his
phraseology but actually he meant All
Nations that comes from the book the
Jesuit
history now but it doesn't look as if he
has this Authority no he looks like a
little man in white sitting there in
Rome uh but he has the sign of Anu in
his
Courtyard so who does he wield this
Authority through through various civil
Powers right who's his main
goto well the Bible tells us in
Revelation
13 11 that there will be another Beast
another kingdom that will arrive out of
the Earth with has this lamb-like
principle but also speaks like the
dragon and that's how the first Beast
Roman Catholicism spoke and he this
second power exercises all the power of
the first Beast before
him this power that is to control the
children of evil on this
Earth had the power that the one before
him had yes and on behalf of him ye yes
because he causes the Earth and them
that dwell there in to worship the first
Beast so he's doing it on behalf of the
first Beast whose deadly wound was
healed yeah so here is the power which
we know can only apply to the United
States of America because it is a lamb
likee power and it must have enough
political power to control issues in the
earth and it must arise when the first
piece Catholicism seems to receive a
mortal wound seems to receive a mortal
wound actually it goes Underground
through its freemasonic powers and rules
the world Incognito through the second
power and the second power arises in the
exact same time period when the first
one yeah receives a moral can be no one
else but the United States there's no
doubt about it and he now has this power
to exercise rule so he must also have
the sign of Anu on behalf of the other
one yeah all right and he is an image
a spitting image he looks the same in
every
aspect and we ask ourselves what is the
aim well the aim is for the church and
State together to rule yes now we talked
about church and state coming together
in the last one that we spoke about so
let's just make sure that this is what
they really want now if we go and look
at this issue we find the Seal of
Georgetown University that's the Jesuit
university that seems to love to educate
presidents yeah and their
children it Bears the founding date of
89 the university motto is UT Unum both
into
one oh and the Latin inscription
colum gorio palatum Adas whatever
which means Georgetown College on the
banks of the pamac in
Maryland it's interesting that the seat
of the government is also in Maryland
right yeah little it sounds like it's a
gift from the Catholic church or a loan
let's put it that
way now here is the Seal of Georgetown
that's a seal Authority seals are very
interesting things
right and it has this eagle with a
shield that we showed earlier wielding
The Sword and it has one foot on the
glob
here and one holding the cross so the
one stands for the spiritual power and
the other one stands for the secular
powers of Earth and they shall be UT
Unum both into one church and state
ruling over the children of this world
the descendants of Cain who largely have
a religion of Salvation by works so we
need to talk about that issue MH
so basically what we're doing Martin
we're moving from the historic aspects
of where we are in the Stream of time
politically which we did in the last
WhatsApp Prof now we're looking at the
spiritual angle and seeing what the
issue is now Catholicism ni denies the
atonement Christ didn't die for you
remember we've dealt with this many many
times and all the other religions of the
world largely have the same philosophy
yeah that it is your works that bring
you into favor with God so modern if the
first Beast Catholicism is the one that
really wields the wheels of power then
we have to ask ourselves well who
founded the organizations and the
structures which give this power unto
the second beast which is America yeah
so if you look at the a it was formed by
William Wild Bill Donovan and he was a
knight of
Malta now when you become a knight of
Malta who do you swear allegiance to the
pope
Aha and the FBI was formed by Joseph
bonapart who happened to be a knight of
Malta and since that time you can go
through history we don't have time to do
this in this present
ation you will see that the Knights of
Malta and the representatives of the
first Beast are the ones that control
these
organizations and the central Hub of
power from the Inception the whole time
and that on that uh statue of uh the
king that was 800 BC there was the
maltes cross on there correct and this
Knights of Malta has got got the same
emblems they have exactly the same
emblem so all of those powers are today
ruling so if we go a little bit further
and we take another quote here from
Freemasonry it says the truth is the
Jesuits of Rome have perfected
Freemasonry to be their most magnificent
and effective tool accomplishing their
purposes amongst
Protestants now there's a little trick
that you apply in in order to do this
you create basically the structures and
then you ban the structures so that you
seem to have distanced yourself from it
and then by Banning it for all Catholics
you draw all the Protestants into it and
you rulle them behind the scenes without
them knowing it this is basically how it
happens so this is the grand from The
Grand Design exposed now let's go back
into
history and we look at shalona
II this is now again an Assyrian King
yeah and he would be the Forerunner of
the Babylonian Kings
right and uh juu is the one that was
given Power by God to punish
Israel right and J was uh is Israel King
is King yes he was anointed as the king
of Israel Elijah had to go and anoint
OED so juu was going to rule over the
disobedient and punish them but jahu was
subject to shalona ah because on the
black Obelisk of shalona you have a
relief of
juu here bowing down to shal
manesa so he was subject to someone he
was subject to the king of Assyria which
is very strange right so here is a a
drawing of what you see in this relief
here on the black Obelisk there is
shalona there's juu kneeling down and
here are those that are presenting the
gifts carrying the gifts and they all
have the same little hat on yeah that is
called the frian hat and it was a symbol
that was used in the French Revolution
very interesting history
and also on that picture is the sign of
Anu again yes exactly here you have the
sign of Anu which means that the one who
yielded it was the king of Assyria he
was basically the one who had The Mark
of Cain he was against God yeah and
against God's people all the
time and he was the one who had the
power to rule over the children of evil
but juu was subject to him very
interesting yeah so God gave juu
authority to rule but then he Israel but
he was under saloner oh under him yes
and they all had this little hat on now
if you had this little hat on then
basically you were like a free man
uhhuh if you are subject to Rome you can
be a free man or if you were subject to
shal Mana you can be a free man so
you're only free as far as according to
them you adhere to the common good
exactly so you have total freedom of
choice and religion as long as you do
what you're told yeah that's what it
boils down to so Martin if we go to the
United
States and we look at their emblem or
their seal if you like of the Senate
which is the highest governing body or
you look at the department of the arm me
you have the same little hat which
happens to be here the Hat of the god
Mitra which is the sun god so the deity
that you had was actually Marduk yeah he
was the he was the son God later he
became in the time of the Ms and
Persians MRA and he had the same little
hat so it was just you know names for
the same God it's interesting that hat
is there in the Senate yes but you you
also see it in in in cartoons uh The
Smurfs have got a similar hat on yes and
uh nauy that little yes he has the Hat
on all of the so definitely they have a
a a point to make that they are ruling
yes and it's also interesting Martin
that here is a symbol very similar to
what you had on the Jesuit one except it
says here out of many one oh on the on
the Georgetown out of the two out of
both one out of the two out of the the
rulers of Earth and and the church
ruling over them so the church claims to
have the sword of the spirit and the
secular sword is subject to it yeah so
the higher sword has the real power of
Anu and bequeaths it ah to the one who's
to wield it and that is the state and in
order to be able to en force it of
course you have the same little hat with
a serpent having the power over it and
that is the Army doing the work on
behalf of the other system so if you go
to this building over
here which is the site of the Scottish
right of Freemasonry it's very close to
the other buildings in Washington where
the rulers come together that's where
the real decisions are probably made
made in the halls of the Masonic temple
to the 33rd Dee Scottish
right and when you enter in there you
will find not only the symbol of here of
the shamash the son God but you'll also
on the door have the sign of Anu yeah
rulers of evil as sworn by shamash and
Muk what's it doing there Martin it you
who wields the power who wields the
power but the real power lies in Rome
because that's where the biggest one is
right now if you go to the US Supreme
Court Martin and you look against the
wall there what do you see the sign of
Anu It's The Sign of Anu so these people
are the ones who have the authority and
the power isn't that interesting that is
amazing didn't you also show that um
Nimrod and the P of Babel when God
confused the languages don't they use
isn't it somewhere that it states that
they use signs as a language because
sign and symbols as a language so here
if you know the signs and you understand
the language you know exactly what it's
saying yeah so different cultures from
right around the world knows EXA if they
know this they know exactly what they're
saying here okay so now if you take the
present government of the United States
of America and we spoke about it in the
last one about the Golden Age and
everything that is going to happen there
many of them whether it was Vance or
whether it was Rubio it didn't really
matter they were not shy to appear with
these signs on their foreheads which
seem to indicate their allegiance to the
first Beast yes because it's only the
first Beast that issues for sure this
ash W's time yeah so they were saying
that they are emissaries m almost
ambassadors of the first past yeah is
that correct that's correct is that what
the Bible says they will be we we have
to have the Seal of God yes in our voice
and in our hands so and it's not
supposed to be a physical sign that you
walk around with because that is very
similar to saying by what I just did by
my works I'm showing that I'm aligned
with a righteousness which comes from
the system rather than from Christ yeah
it's also showing whose authority is
you're accepting exactly so when church
and state actually comes together out of
both one
yeah which is basically against the
Constitution of the United States which
separates church and state which the
current head of Congress says is based
on bad history you're actually
repudiating the Constitution yeah yeah
so we read in testimonies for the church
Volume 5
our country shall repudiate every
principle of its Constitution as a
Protestant and Republican government and
shall make provision for the propagation
of papal falsehoods are we seeing them
you can see it on the forehead and
Illusions then we may know that the time
has come for The Marvelous working of
Satan and that the end is near Mar is
the writing on the wall for sure but not
everybody will know know what that
writing is saying exactly not even the
leaders because we read also in another
statement there are not many even among
Educators in statement who comprehend
the causes that underly the present
state of society those who hold the
Reigns of government are not able to
solve the problem of moral
corruption poverty popism and increased
crime so we have all of these cartels
and we have all of these movements and
they're trying to smash this one and
break that one but it seems as though
matters just get worse you know you have
the fenel crisis and all of these now
there's a there's a hope for a golden
era and this Euphoria but let's see they
are struggling in vain to place business
operations on a more secure basis would
you say that the the the world is in an
economic turmoil at the moment well I
hope everybody can see that if men would
give more heed to the teaching of God's
word they would find the solution of the
problems that perplex them but they
don't they don't find the solution
because they don't seek them there they
seek them in power of Anu yeah in The
Mark of Cain so then we're also told
that there will be economic chaos and
then the Great Deceiver will persuade
men that those who serve God are causing
the evils there will be tornadoes there
will be catastrophes there will be more
drugs coming in there will be all kinds
of Economic
chaoses and the class that has provoked
the displeasure of heaven will charge
all their troubles upon those who
obedience to God's Commandments is a
Perpetual reproof to
transgressors it will be declared that
men are offending God by the violation
of the Sunday Sabbath that this sin has
brought
calamities which will not cease until
Sunday observance shall be strictly
enforced and that those who present the
claims of the fourth Commandment which
embodies the Seal of God yeah as we saw
scripturally thus destroying reverence
for Sunday are troublers of the people
preventing their restoration to Divine
favor and temporal
Prosperity so Martin if you want to go
to this Golden Age you have to get
people back in line and obedient to the
system and the laws will have to become
more and more Draconian in order to do
that finally they will say we have to
get morality back we have to get people
back to God but the question is which
God the one who puts the ash on your
head or the one that puts the Seal of
God in your forehead isn't that the
choice that's the choice sure and uh if
you look at current events and what's
happening we must be very close these
these laws cannot be it's not improbable
that it cannot that it can happen pretty
soon yes I think the last events will be
rapid luns so this is where we're
talking about this golden age that must
be brought about and every single one of
these is propagating a Utopia here on
Earth whereas the Bible says it'll go
from bad to worse and then the kingdom
of God will be set up and all of the the
political systems on Earth will be
destroyed exactly didn't the previous
citation say temporal Prosperity yes we
have developed in great detail what we
are calling the gold card which goes on
sale very very soon
for $5 million we will allow the most
successful job creating people from all
over the world to buy a path to US
citizenship it's like the green card but
uh better and more
sophisticated as Commander in Chief my
focus is on building the most powerful
military of the future as a first step
I'm asking Congress to fund a
state-of-the-art golden dome missile
defense shield to protect our homeland
all made in the
USA other places have it and the United
States should have it too right Tim
right they should have it too so I want
to thank you but it's a very very
important this is a very dangerous world
we should have it we want to be
protected and we're going to protect our
citizens like never
before I believe that my life was saved
that day in Butler for a very good
reason I was saved by God to make
America great again I believe
[Music]
that now it is our time to take up the
righteous cause of American Liberty and
it is our turn to take America's Destiny
into our own hands and begin the most
thrilling days in the history of our
country this will be our greatest ERA
with God's help over the next four years
we are going to lead this nation even
higher and we are going to forge the
freest most advanced most dynamic and
most dominant civilization ever to exist
on the face of this Earth we are going
to create the highest quality of life
build the safest and wealthiest and
healthiest and most vital communities
anywhere in the world we are going to
conquer the vast frontiers of Science
and we are going to lead Humanity into
space and plant the American flag on the
planet Mars and even far
beyond my fellow Americans get ready for
an incredible future because the Golden
Age of America has only just begun it
will be like nothing that has ever been
seen before thank you God bless you and
God bless America that was worth showing
again I think so too there was an
interesting thing that I picked up that
I didn't pick up most dominant and
building ah Nimrod was a great Builder
Cain was a great Builder Enoch was a
builder Herod was a great Builder now
there's nothing wrong with being great
Builders but if that building is in
Contra position to what God has in mind
then M we're in an interesting time the
most
dominant does that sound like wielding
the the sign ofo
oh so we are also warned that the labor
unions will be very prominent the wicked
are being bound up into bundles bound up
in trusts in unions in confederacies
that us have nothing to do with these
organization God is our ruler our
governor and he calls us to come out
from the world and be separate so Martin
we are seeing the Clash of a can Spirit
yeah against a abble spirit yeah the one
is salvation by works and absolute
control and the other one is submission
and Reliance on a power outside of
yourself the two are very different
mindsets very different
indeed so when these evils that will
take place on the earth because this
will not be so easy to perform as they
claim you will see that the very class
the leaders who have taught the law of
God is Not binding put forth the claim
that the far spreading corruption is
attributed to the desecration of the
so-called Christian Sabbath and that the
enforcement of Sunday observance would
greatly improve the morals of society
that's the next step on the right this
claim is especially urged in
America where the doctrine of the true
Sabbath has been most widely preached
very interesting statement I'm looking
with interest to the Future to to see
when this moral step will be
taken and who will it come from who will
demand this Sunday
observance well according to the great
controversy political corruption is
destroying love of justice and regard
for truth are they unearthing a lot of
corruption
Doge you're right and even in free
America rulers and legislators in order
to secure public favor will yield to the
popular Dem demand for a law enforcing
Sunday observance Liberty of conscience
which has cost so great a sacrifice will
no longer be
respected isn't Trump boasting about
winning the popular the popular vote Yes
and every single other one swing stat
all of that isn't that a precursor of
the
people saying what they want correct I
didn't invite the oligarchs of the world
to buy a $5
million gold card in order to further
this dream of
prosperity the same with every you'll
put tariffs if you don't build it Build
It in America and that's why everybody
you won't you can come and do it in
there this Golden Country but what does
the Bible say Martin it says go too now
ye rich man weep and howl for your
miseries shall come upon you your riches
are corrupted and your garments are moth
eaten your gold and silver is cankered
and the rust of them shall be a witness
against you and shall eat your flesh as
it were fire you have heaped Treasures
together for the last
days so many of these multibillionaire
philanthropists how much of that
trickles down to the poor person they
don't care and then we'll have the
influence of spiritualism at the same
time
so as spiritualism more closely imitates
the nominal Christianity of the day it
has greater power to deceive and Des
snare this is fire coming down from
heaven false
outpourings Satan himself is converted
after the modern order of things he will
appear in the character of an angel of
Light through the agency of spiritualism
Miracles will be wrought the sick will
be healed and many undeniable wonders
will be performed and as the spirits
will profess faith in the Bible and
manifest respect for the institutions of
the church which church yep Rome yep
their work will be accepted as a
manifestation of divine power so all of
this mingled together is what we can
expect in these last days and then we
will have a time of
trouble such as never was since there
was a nation even to that time and the
good news is at that time your people
shall be delivered everyone who's found
written in the book Martin how close are
we well I believe very
close Revelation 20 verse4 tells us and
I saw
Thrones and they that sat upon them and
judgment was given unto them and I saw
the souls of them that were beheaded for
the witness of Jesus and for the word of
God and which had not worshiped the
Beast neither his image nther had
received his Mark upon their foreheads
or in their hands and they lived and
reigned with Christ a thousand years so
even though they're The Underdogs
here yeah in Christ they will have the
victory they will have the victory over
the
Beast and they will have the victory
over the image so these two pictures
over here this conglomerate Beast with
all the elements of Babylon and met I
and Greece and Greece and Rome in it and
the sign of Anu that has been handed
down Martin that Victory will go to
God's people and Jesus what does it say
he will do Revelation 1915 and out of
his mouth goes a sharp sword that with
it he should Smite the
Nations that doesn't sound like a a
golden age of acknowledgement to me does
it no that sounds more like that rock
that comes to destroy the king correct
and he shall rule them with a rod of
iron and treadeth the wine press of the
fierceness and wroth of almighty
God and 1 Corinthians 15:24 says then
cometh the end when he shall have
delivered up the kingdom to God even the
father when he shall have put down all
Rule and all authority and power which
rule and author Authority and power
those that rule with the sign of
Anu and which was was the line of Cain
Martin the rulers of evil we are in the
closing scenes of Earth's
history and we can expect some very
fascinating events in the near future
the seal or the Mark what's your choice
definitely the seal let's pray
Heavenly
Father we pray earnestly that we will
be in the fortunate position to be
empowered by the god of Heaven to accept
the Seal of almighty God seal up the law
in the
testimony and that seal of authority in
the heart of the law with your name and
your title and your jurisdiction
cannot be moved even if the other one
said he stands above the Bible and has
the power to do it and we have to bow to
the authentic teaching of the church and
observe the mark of the beast or else be
designated a
heretic may we make the right choice in
jesus' name amen amen
[Music]